ننقل لكم المشهد والصوره هنا من حي التفاح
في مقبره البرش هذه المقبره التي كان
يتواجد بها جثامين الشهداء هنا جثه لشهيد
وهنا جثه لشهيد وكل هذه المقبره جثث
لجثامين الشهداء التي تم نبشها خلال تمركز
اليات الاحتلال داخل هذه المقبره تم نبش
جميع الجثت في داخل المقبره واخراجها من
باطن الارض الى سطح الارض كما تشاهدون
تماما في هذه المقبره عوده الاهالي لدفن
جمين شهداء في هذه المقبره التي كانت تضم
جمين الشهداء هذا الاحتلال المجرم والهمجي
الذي لا يحترم حرمه الاموات وحرمه شهدائنا
ننقل لكم المشهد والصوره تماما لهذه
العائلات التي تعيد دفن جمين شهدائها بعد
نبش في داخل هذه المقبره في حي التفاح
ننقل لكم المشهد
والصوره حسبنا الله ونعم
الوكيل
l